did we do we start this live stream or
not okay
great all right well for people
that was the michael anti
uh
entry introduction here the introduction
of what we are going to do
is talk about
uh
biomolecular sequence functions
um
which apparently i don't have code for
but this is going to be so this is going
to be a
a uh
uh
what what do they call it when you write
code on paper paper coding exercise or
something what is that
yeah
um
okay all right
so
biosequence
wait a minute biosequence
okay so biosequence
is something that we've had in 12 when
when have we introduced it twelve two
right right
okay so a typical biosequence
in the wild
would be something like
um
like this
and does that okay
so now
you are proposing
a new
piece to biosequence which is
what tentacles hang out of the thing is
that right
that's right
okay
so
go ahead oh yeah that will be adding um
bonds and
between the sequences themselves and
also connecting to other sequences as
appropriate okay so so i'm just trying
to understand
when you define a sequence there are
series of characters here these
characters have character positions
that's what you're referring to here is
that correct that's right
does that is that even vaguely sensible
i mean in other words guys with respect
to molecules we also have some kind of
positional specification of things it's
that corrective atoms in our molecule
so can we give an example of uh if i
take a molecule for example here and i
say
something like this
um
what i'm then doing if i look at the
input form of that
that will reference
yes that will reference bonds by
in that list it will reference bonds by
their position here is that correct i
mean they will reference atoms by their
position right it's essentially a graph
with indices as the vertices and
everything you see there are the
annotations on the uh on the vertices
and edges yeah recording that's not if i
were to actually write down a graph and
i would say graph abc
and then i were to say here
one goes to two three goes to four it's
going to be just totally confused great
oh it isn't confused
why isn't that confused
one goes to two oh i see it you throw i
see i see it is confused it is confused
those are disjoint nodes a b and c are
disjoint nodes that have nothing to do
with the nodes referenced in the edges
specification
correct correct
okay whereas here
you are choosing t to reference
so instead i don't know whether this is
supported in graph it could be you could
imagine an association here which says
one goes to o two goes to whatever two
goes to o et cetera and that that was
how you are what those indices there are
referring to
but otherwise it's just a magic indexing
of that first argument that's happening
here is that correct
so
yes but i prefer to think of it as it
would be a graph where the first the
first element of the first list is
annotation
one
comma
atomic symbol goes to o
i see okay
okay fine i mean the same word cap is
complex or mesh region
right fine okay so the generalization
here
is that we're
borrowing into character strings to do
this
that's right
and
it is the case is it not
that characters
is
sort of as if so for example if i were
to take this
and i would just make that into a single
string
okay you wouldn't expect molecule to
work in that case
but you are expecting biosequence to
work in that case is that correct that
that's right modulated character set
right i was going to bring that up i
mean so in other words the the
decomposition into positions
is done by
by
list
index a part of the return of characters
is that correct
yeah okay does that apply when you have
like a peptide too are you using single
lettering coatings for everything yeah
we're using single encodings for
everything
we might have different way
there's the reason why the we are able
to represent the sequences as strings of
characters because we can represent each
nucleotide or each amino acid by one
letter whereas in the molecule case it
is possible for an atom to have a two
letter separate three letters or joining
stuff joining stuff into a strange
machine
okay but so brian are you raising that
because with some non-standard biology
you might end up with something that
wasn't specifiable as a one character
thing
uh yeah i mean you play games with like
uppercase lowercase to get past you know
26 but
no i understand that but i'm saying is
there a standard thing if i'm you know
it is normal to see it as three
characters is the i don't know in my
world that when people see peptides they
tend to use the three character
representations because it's tough to
memorize 26
encodings
right start to get a little odd after a
while okay so the question really here
is
if is it the case the biosequence if i
were to feed it
right now
instead of this i would defeat it well
if i just do it right here if i were to
feed it characters of that does it just
get confused or does it happily take it
doesn't take it
no
it does not
it's yeah it gets into undocumented
behavior
all right yeah
we come back to this later in this
notebook on the left
okay but so so if we allowed that if we
allowed biosequence to take a list there
then this can just be a shorthand for
that list much as smiles as a shorthand
for molecules correct
in which scent would it be shortened
well in other words if you just give a
string
a multicar in other words there are two
signatures a string
which is decomposed using characters
and a list of objects which are taken
one each one is each sort of successive
token to be used
but currently it looks like it tries to
parse a list of strings as a list of
biosequences
but
which would be another
letter is interpreted as a
sequence that only has one
element okay so so that's the problem
then so i mean in other words we've got
two we've got a conflicting
okay if we were to support something
beyond a string
the question is is there another rapper
we could give that would deal with that
or is it the case that we want a
biosequence which is two you know two so
right now if i say
biosequence of a list of things what is
it going to do a list of of non-trivial
you know
pieces right
okay i hate that message by the way i
hate that message but we never have
those kinds of messages in the system
but whatever at least it's informative
for us i suppose
that wrapper by the way is what we use
at emerald so we have a different head
for say dna or peptide and
that's how we know it's internal inside
it right
but s8 this is in the notebook on the
left so we should come back to this
discussion maybe all right okay
okay
so
okay so the first thing you're showing
here is there is a way of having
unfilled tentacles at the end
no no the the point is not the end the
point is the weakness
alone yeah okay fine i see i see i see
so this is saying these are additional
bonds
that can occur
in
anywhere so this means
this is a zipper basically is that right
right yeah this was one of the things
it's a little bit in non standard use
why
it's a span those are two spans yes
right
and
so this is
this thing here that's very weird that's
a that's a backwards span there i'm i'm
a little bit confused about what's
happening here is this a single zipper
or is this multiple zippers
that's a single zipper
okay let me let me look at me unzip the
zip how can i even do an unzipped zipper
it's equivalent to the form above so
or should be
that would be in the immediate form the
immediate form would be
uh
two three four five six eighteen
seventeen
up to thirteen yes
because if you look at the string in one
direction you go forward when you come
back you go backwards
yes i i
understand i understand i understand
that that's atom
right well it's not atom it's
it's whatever residue or whatever that
is yeah residue
the um
okay i don't object to this uh that it
seems okay to me are we fixed on the
phrase hydrogen for the bonds there
that's a little mixed metaphor with
what we're doing with molecule
oh yeah that's terrible
even if it's the second argument of bond
well in this case a hydrogen technically
like gc has three hydrogen bonds in ats
ii
if you go to the so you'd have to reuse
hydraulics
you might call it like watson correct
pair or something else like that yeah
it still works as a one to one but it's
not tech just so it doesn't get confused
okay yeah
you're saying there are ordinary
hydrogen bonds that that live in
chemistry in general and these are not
they
is that what you're saying yeah these
are composed of like multiple of they so
like the gc will have three hydrogen
bonds between energy and see
that kind of thing you would have two
hydrogen bonds
between them yes it's not specifically
one bond between two atoms it's a it's
it's an edge between two so here the the
yeah the vertices are monomers and so
it's it's a connection well so so the
but there is a notion of hydrogen
bonding that would be relevant
potentially for molecules as well oh
absolutely right right that's why i just
heard namespace confusion you might call
it like pairing or watson quick pairing
or something rather
watson crick is a good choice
fine
the it always makes me it's always but
when we name things after people i've
actually i actually know or have known
it's always
it's always different from just these
these things named after 19th century
mathematicians and so on
um
well if you don't want to include names
you could do a hydrogen collection
because you have more than one hydrogen
bond from a molecule sense
i i think that's i think it's better to
if that if that's what base pair would
be a generic name you'd call it a base
pair that would be a good name that
would be a good name that's an easier to
honestly that's a better unders you know
better known name
and this could also be used for peptides
or this would be just for dna and rna
for peptides you don't get
yeah you get like disulfide bonds which
are different yeah and those are really
one-to-one so that's like okay that
works in both spaces of molecule and
biosequence
that's actually what i had planned for
the peptide version of this so the
disulfide would be the string specified
in the second argument of bonds
yeah but secondary structures also held
together by hydrogen bonds and peptides
both alpha helix and beta sheets yeah
that's that's another question
but so if we call it something like base
pairing or something a type of bond what
is what is that bond it's a because the
base pair is the base pair you know cg
or whatever
but this is the bond that bonds that
bonds together that base pair
comments
stack of the three two or three hydrogen
bonds between the two
it's what everyone logically thinks of
what's paired with what even
energetically it's actually not even the
most important thing the stack between
the up and down is what's
providing some of the stabilization
energy for the whole thing
but everyone still logically thinks of
it as like the connection
between them fair enough but then i'm
just asking what should the name be for
this type of bond
base pair is totally reasonable yeah
just base pair or base pairing
oh
see i think it should be this paragraph
because it is the bond right it is not
the base pair itself that's the point
i'm making oh yeah at this point
bass player wouldn't sounds good
basically even in is the specific uh
instance of aeu or ap and cg
so wait a minute are you saying base
pairing is good because i i don't like
baseball i would just be i would use
bass player because bass paving it no it
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
the bass pair
is c and g it is not the bond that joins
c and g
so we can call it base pair bond i
suppose
what do we do
we do yeah we don't use bond on single
double triple though
um okay well fine but then
well okay maybe maybe okay bob what do
you think
i i was going for base pair bond and uh
in the chemistry
world hydrogen bond as well that we
don't have yet but we've been talking
about also i see so you're saying
instead of to call it name it that and
name it hydrogen bond so we're not
calling it so we don't have the
weirdness of having a bond called
hydrogen so to speak yes that that as
well
that it's not a single hydrogen bond
between these no no no no no no no no no
no no bob is saying when we have
hydrogen bonds in ordinary molecular
chemistry um
that's just between two atoms in case
i'm going to do a single bond double
bond oh no no it would have i mean so it
would have to follow like that right but
so the issue is what we have right now
is single and double that's those are
the names there right right yes
yeah i just say single double triple
okay fine the question is whether we
rename those whether we say we prefer
single bond double bond triple bond
or whether we just call those single and
double and then what do we do with these
other ones
because the outer head is already bond i
think the shorter world is more natural
for me that makes more sense to me all
right okay okay basically hydrogen then
it's a type of bond
yeah yep i still don't know what i mean
what are the situations where it's
necessary to specify a second argument
in this so isn't it by biosequence and
then a sequence we know what type of
sequence it is and you're giving bonds
between them
um what
what does having the freedom to specify
what type of bond it is
what does that give you
that'll matter if you do you know
hookstein pairing and other more
complicated things than
the default could perfectly well be a
base pair bond between base pairs for
example
further down on the notebook john
explains that uh you don't have to
specify it it will do what's natural and
if it can it will use a generic name
um and
the main chain also has bonds as it were
between residues
and i i don't recall the name that uses
for those
what's what they ester
yes
phosphodiester bonds
in the primary structure
okay but so what's it going to be called
here that that bond were we to annotate
it
which
so so you're saying there are implicitly
bonds on the backbone
that's right right yes yes but but which
we are not explicitly naming but were
you to put up between one and two
which we did
we did i think it's somewhere down the
that's not
great okay but fine but but so if we had
a bond between one and two which we
choose to explicitly give what would it
be called
because what the yesterday is the
string we used
okay i don't know how to spell that but
that'll be that's fine i'm sure it'll
auto complete
um
okay
okay fair enough
all right
okay so this is just the defaulting of
bond types that's fine composite strands
okay what is this about okay so we we've
now dealt with the
additional bonds
so
just to understand
in a biosequence this phosphodiester
bond thingy is assumed to be the
backbone default
that's right
so one day
if we were to do other
heteropolymers or whatever
there might be a different backbone
default bond
indeed
so
to have dinocle acids uh the
phosphodiester may be replaced by some
other connection like was followed by
amide i think uh the emerald people
are aware of other possible nucleic acid
uh connections okay there's all kinds of
fun you can put in there but the most
common one is if you do peptide you're
gonna have you know peptide bonds
between them
so when we move farther to have hetero
polymers or even larger extended
macromolecules ideally
the monomer themselves would have
defined connection points and there
there there would be some natural
bond that forms between two uh given
monomers
what we're saying is what i'm
understanding is the default right now
implicit or perhaps an explicit option i
don't know is that for this biosequence
that it's backbone
if those things are
uh you know bases the backbone is this
if the things that are
uh you know peptides the backbone is the
amino acids the backbone is this
is that's correct
okay
and and what happens if i mix
i mean what do i get if i mix
a specification of a i mean i don't
actually know how these work oh i see
i've got to say the thing i've got is
rna or the thing i've got is a protein
is that correct that's right
okay so that defines what the default
backbone is
and and i see so in other words if we
were going to put in a wacky custom
object that's the you know the worm that
lives on europa or something that has um
uh you know some different kind of thing
we would essentially be changing this
first argument of biosequence to specify
a different kind of uh
petropolymer is that correct
yes
and that someone would have to specify
what kind of default backbone one that
the new header polymer should use
it's an intrinsic property of that one
um
i'm sorry i wasn't i didn't understand
that could you say that again
so in dna or rna we assume that the
phosphodiester one is
the the main one used by the by this
it's an intrinsic property of that type
of bisequence so if someone were to
specify some new kind of uh
heteropolymer he would also have to
specify that exactly what kind of name
to use
yes
um
let's see n a on our live stream asks
any chance of using dot kernel notation
for dna sequences i don't know what that
is can somebody speak to that
i know about dot dot bracket notation
which is a way of specifying
uh these
secondary structure bonds
and i have
i have done some i guess examples using
that i was maybe planning on doing a wfr
around that but if it's if it's popular
we could certainly include it but so
this is a smiley like thing where you
have parentheses or something in the
string
or you have a second string with
parentheses and brackets that specify
the bonds and yeah
there's a group at cal who has pioneered
a lot of that stuff it's probably just
right up on their website we'd go check
it
okay
well all right but so it's a different
way it's a more smiles like way of
specifying this kind of secondary
structure information is that correct
i think so in the first approximation
yes what's it called dot kernel notation
that's what the person on live stream
says yes
okay i mean so we've been looking into a
few different uh
linear line notations for this
helm is the one thing we've been looking
at a few months ago
okay let's move on composite strands
um ah yes indeed the this was a caltech
lab
uh link
being sent
good okay
um
all right so
i'm curious to pull it up and see what
it is
um
mostly uh eric eric one freeze group
oh okay
and there
there's many more have joined since then
but it's like him and niles pierce back
in the day
okay
well i'm
i'm glad my random suggestion when he
was being a research assistant to me
panned out into such a giant like the
basis of my whole thesis man yeah it's
huge okay
um
it's a motivation to suggest more more
projects to more people
that which i do all the
time eminence greece
what the
is that the french phrase
and the bible yeah behind all these
things yes yes yes there yeah right i
was
your
my french pronunciation will be even
worse
i'm sorry if i butchered it
the okay
all right so
um
i mean that by the way that does seem
like a very relevant thing so we should
look at it
okay let's look at composite strands
here
so now we take a few different ones
include them together linear it's still
the sequence that's the main point
we don't do any branching
right
but so so what is the bond here at that
this i don't quite understand it's
awesome
okay so i i don't know how these things
bond but but um
bind but okay so you can do that i mean
can i put a protein here no i can't
right no because it's not
at least there's no
one way to connect a
peptide to a nucleic acid there's
multiple ways and you'd have one would
have to specify what kind of attachment
is
being done to support that
okay
yeah you might call that a conjugate
at the end of the day uh nuclear protein
yes
but i don't understand what this so the
question here is
to have this outer wrapper
of a composite strand so right now the
second argument of biosequence tends to
be just a string of characters that
represent the the elements of this
petropolymer thing whereas here you're
saying it could be whole strands in that
second argument is that correct yeah
that's right
seems okay to me
i mean i i do kind of wonder what
happens if you have a weird branch thing
but maybe this this particular backbone
doesn't allow branching presumably
now because they come in linear sequence
it cannot branch
yeah
okay
by the way is this so this is the new
biosequence plot
um
made with a prototype of it yes
right okay
it has a certain you know it could say
happy birthday or something it has a
certain
[Laughter]
do we like do we like the general
graphic has it has it gone through
graphic design no
okay
does anybody want to comment on what
what roughly it should look like i mean
does
is is this kind of
i mean is this roughly right or is this
uh like not what you would expect what
would you expect to see if somebody
publishes it in their grand paper in
nature what should it look like
when secondary structure shows up those
are definitely traditional i think the
different shapes on the backbone
that's something we did at emerald
to distinguish one backbone for another
backbone chemistry
but that's less normal than just seeing
the
bonds but the general graph like the one
from the top of the page
that's completely normal to see
something like that okay
when we make it google search secondary
structural dna you get tons of them okay
all right fine well we'll yeah that's a
graphic design discussion i don't think
we have anybody from there in this
meeting
we should note that we get a colorblind
friendly color scale
since the colors show something
different than the shape because the
shape shows the matches the letter
or no excuse me i'm wrong but either way
color blind friendly color scheme would
be important
okay
um all right self-bonded composite
strand
now it gets a little bit more
interesting with respect to the indexing
sure does
so
this bond so this is
something where the where a composite
strand says i'm going to take one index
from the first thing and one next from
the second thing is that right
what if i gave three things in that
first element
if it's a if it's a single number in the
bond it's for the whole length of the
strand for this strand and
for these strand indexes oh boy okay so
it's it's a
oh boy it's a concatenated part number
really right
really is that really a good idea
no they are below is the alternative or
edition
um i understand i understand that's a
more full form but i mean that's a
that's a are you saying that these are
both things that you would recommend
using or are you saying it's we could i
mean this one looks to me kind of crazy
this one looks to me unbelievably
unmodular as in if you say i'm going to
add a you know a character here and it's
like boom
something you know to do with the you
know the fifth sequence
got misaligned that doesn't seem like a
very good thing
right i mean to me i was thinking we
could support both but
we don't have to support the linear one
the fully linear one
no i think we should go with the second
one the modular one the the argument
stephen just made about doing an
insertion in one of the segments
completely makes everything downstream
broken
right i'm just wondering is there a case
in which
the composite strand i mean this is a
question for users of this stuff in
which the composite strand really is
thought of as being you know
sequentially accessed
or are these different sections going to
be ingested by a different part of the
animal so to speak
they're generally thought of as
consistently one thing like there are
there are concepts of things like
gapmers where literally every other base
you'll do
like a different backbone chemistry
but you think of it as one sequence at
the end of the day that you produce what
are they used for these composite
sequences do they show up in biology
not naturally but in therapeutics they
show up all the time like all the new
antisense
yes yeah but also multi-strand peptides
uh or you know proteins
that have multiple strands
they're not
they mean they will be positive they're
a composite but but the ends aren't well
actually no then they're not
uh you could so you're saying a protein
would logically be like a series of
peptides that are broken up
sometimes people do that yeah region is
this you know we call it this region
yeah um these were in john's uh
nomenclature further down notebook they
they fall under the collection
okay
we're clearly the thumb is not far down
so maybe i should look further down here
also people think you're providing
machinery to go from one indexing to the
other so that if you really wanted to
insert one you could go to the
part one insert and go back
because sometimes this is more
convenient sometimes this
i understand i understand okay i mean
it's horrifying to have functions that
do such a conversion but let's keep
looking is the term composite strand
fixed too
because you might call that a chimera is
the sort of natural phrasing people
would use for something like that
the magic sounds yeah
but you might get that
in synthetic context too you'd still
call it that
and does that apply to proteins also
probably no because your backbone
chemistry doesn't often change in
in the peptide world it's like the
it's a logical grouping of a region or a
group right therefore
if
if you're not in the field then
composite strand is more
it's it's more clear to someone who's
not in the field what it is uh if you're
outside the field then you think it's a
mythical
beast right
and nobody i haven't seen anybody refer
to your protein
we're pretty in the weeds though i mean
making chimeras is something that
you're already at phd level right right
you're not going to learn this in bio
101
true right your user your user base is
going to know that word for sure
well depends on yeah okay we could
accept it and then normalize to
something more traditional
i i don't cut the thing that bothers me
about composite strand is the thing is
an end-to-end composite
which is not obvious
i mean a composite strand could be
something that has
multiple parallel to me
not knowing anything
but
let's let's let's keep going here i
think this is i consider this okay i
think the chimera thing what's that
mixed mix trend
that might be better
i mean we're making up this term
for some reason necklace comes to mind
for me but it's not science but that's
the the the that gets
i mean why are we in terms
hybrid strand sounds very reasonable to
me
and it's shorter
that doesn't matter it's all auto
completed anyway okay all right let's
let's keep going here
keeping track of indices can be
cumbersome you don't say
um
okay what what are we doing here is this
whole section about how we deal with
the labeling oh my gosh okay the label
potential
conveniences for
dispense
okay okay so the question is is there
going to be another meeting
x amount of time from now where we're
talking about tensor tensor networks or
something
or neural nets or whatever but we're
going to have the exact same problem of
matching things up like this
and where we're going to say oh well if
we'd only had so what is the basic
problem here the basic problem here is
you've got
some lists
and you are trying to pair up elements
from different lists is that a true
statement that's right
i think let's characterize it
okay so what will be the general way
that we would think about doing that so
we've got two lists
and they're you know a b c d
e
another list is
of a different length
x y z w for example okay
now what what are you trying to do here
you're trying to say
what pairs with what
right
i mean the trivial one would be you just
list them but assume basically that both
lists are long and you have long
contiguous
strengths with a pattern
right i understand i understand so the
question then is what are
some typical things you might want to do
you might want to for example you might
want
i don't even know you might want the
beginning of this
paired with the reversed of this or
something exactly yeah yes
so
the issue then is okay so it's a
question of
um
and you've got a whole bunch of of wacky
forwards backwards whatever things to
specify that which may be the only
option i mean i don't know
i mean
this is more or less brainstorming this
is not obviously the final version okay
but but then so what we've got normally
for indexing into a list we've got you
know we've got lists of parts
we've got spans
you know we have in some sense band but
it's slightly different world
that's for multi-dimensional
right except
i mean doesn't band um
uh
right um
but i mean in a sense okay
okay so again
we've got
a matching
of spans right that's the typical case
yeah am i right yeah yes
so it's
what the heck is this thing here
so what is this three two
oh i think second piece of the compound
one
i see that span
is being mapped onto
so what happens if these spans are
different lengths
then you can't map
what do you get an error message yeah so
a new realistic trance well the molecule
self-destructs
um
okay so those spans
any two spans that are mapped onto each
other have to be
okay
but you could have say in the second one
twice as long list and then have in the
last argument minus two
fine okay so but these are extract specs
is that a correct statement these lists
here
that's not a list you have a typo there
but this list is an extract spec is that
true
if i say this no i don't think so
because is it
we extract uh
second components are going from first
to last in steps of one
paired with the fourth component going
from last to first in steps minus one no
no i understand that but i'm asking if
we were look the way to think about this
is the following
whatever the whatever the identifier is
okay so here's a concept that basically
what bond is doing is it's taking some
indices i 1i2 blah blah blah
that bond is fundamentally going to do
this
it's fundamentally going to have
etc
comma
j1
etc etc etc j2 etc etc etc
and
okay and that then
actually there's two ways to think about
this okay a better way to think about
this will be in terms of the transpose
because in the transpose you're
guaranteed you'll never have hanging
things in it in other words that the
final canonical form that you're trying
to achieve is a sequence of
i sub n's j sub n's
does that make sense
yeah right so the bond the generic bond
the the simplest version of the bond
is just so this is essentially a
listable bond
so an ordinary bond will be which is
presumably i mean that's actually what's
happening at the molecular level as it
is kind of a listable bond
yes
so
it may be just
more ugly to fight down in the general
no i i know that so i'm saying the
question is then if this is the
canonical form if this listable bond is
the canonical form now the question is
how do we write some shorthand that
allows you to specify
that more easily okay and essentially
what you're saying is
that
what you typically want
is
you know is very much like a span a
start
and end a step
for each one of them
right for the eyes and for the j's
so it seems to me
this can be the canonical form which if
you're generating this programmatically
might be the thing you generate
thinking thinking about this
but
but this unfortunately is a transposed
version of that that is you know that's
the starter the end i the step i
and that so then it's a transposed
version that will be a start j here etc
um
it would be nice to know what extract
really does with spans
um
well that would be my suggestion is
those two possibilities
and i do favor allowing this one because
i think it's useful to have something
which is easily programmatically
generatable
comments
but yeah but in this case you could just
as easily generate the points one by one
do you mean a list of bonds yes
it's only a minor
addition that has okay okay okay fair
point
but but look if that's the concept of
what the thing is representing
i mean your point is why use that syntax
for something you can generate easily
another way exactly
you just have n more times the world
point otherwise it's the same
is there precedent in the field to use
the the shorthand uh you know specifying
a range of
residue positions
and a second range of residue
positions i i'm assuming that's the
origin of trying to use spam
i don't know
we did that
just naturally but
don't be prejudiced by the way we went
on i don't think that there's uniform
consensus on how to do it externally
okay
all right
let's we're going to run out of time
here so i just want to expand s
scan forward here
comment from richard on the live stream
about bionetgen
which
apparently is a language for specifying
biochemical simulations i do not know
about it anybody here know about it
a domain-specific pattern calculus
richard says
interesting i'll look into it
okay
um
okay
next up uh
all right so let me just understand that
the general structure of this
oh my gosh we've got a lot of stuff to
go over here
we're gonna have another meeting
well this looks lovely let's do a quick
scan here okay
not going in as much detail
um
but for now you're fine with the
specification of the
spans then we can go ahead i think so
okay i think so okay
i mean
okay
and you also find this the mixed end and
or hybrid
so then we can implement
um
what is this
oh this is this is some flattenability
some
comp of hybrid strands
um
i i had one comment about that um
if if it does flatten like that
uh then you you can't have a starter
uh a hybrid strand and then append to it
programmatically i had the same comment
but i do see the value of this
i mean we could always in the worst case
let normal do this
uh or you have to start if you want to
iteratively build one up you'd have to
start with two of them two elements to
it i think we're talking about this is
the
i mean these hybrid strands already a
sophisticated thing
and this auto melting of one hybrid
strand into another seems like a very
obscure thing
it's basically one replacement rule if
people wanted to do it
yeah i mean i don't think
i know why we're supporting this
particularly right now it seems like we
don't know much about hybrid strands to
begin with and supporting this when we
might you know
i mean maybe there's some giant area of
technology that's going to develop along
these lines where we're going to want to
annotate it differently
by the way for the live stream is
suggesting a a
operator form of bond where you can say
bond of quotes hydrogen and then span
one span two
i like this when you can basically get
what you want that have the bond at it
and when you have a nice short form of
it
by mapping it over
right
um i mean it might canonicalize to
something the other form but having an
operator form a bond seems sensible
well maybe is it possible wait a minute
doesn't bond no no what does it default
to that may not be possible because it
doesn't bond with to uh with a single
argument default to a single bond it
does
so we're toast there can't work i mean
unless we do something special for the
string
today we could do something special for
the strings
think about it not sure let's span scan
forward here
um
does it just recover in your subface
i just want to look forward to what's
happening here
collections of sequences
now cannot come something new basically
that's kind of different thing now
oh my gosh what's this
that's now basically putting the two
things from the beginning the hydrogen
bonds and multiple sequences together so
we have two compounds or hybrids and
they
connect to each other but only through
hydrogen not to primary bonds
and what the heck are these things now
what are those
so we need more indices
yeah first sequence
second motif
second position what is the motif a
motif is part of this hybrid strand
right any uh anything that's kind of all
one color here
the motif is the first motif is atcg
[Music]
well you didn't tell me this when we
were talking about these other indexings
before
and that's why you care about the
flattenability of hybrid strands that's
right
yes
because otherwise you're indexing into a
structure here which is basically
instead of a
sort of a tensor rank you're in a hybrid
a certain hype
hybrid rank so to speak i mean you might
have it
we could trust not to port it
kind of saying if you want such a
composite one then composite yourself
you can't have nesting
i i just think this is look
i i want to know is this an actual
active area of people building molecules
this way is this something people really
do a lot
it's uh definitely niche but
like the vaccines and stuff that you
guys are
taking for covid it's all the nucleic
acid stuff that's blowing up right now
so i have like
easily over half a dozen startups
working on this type of thing and
i know a lot of
big pharma companies doing this type of
thing too but it is definitely niche
within
that scientific community
okay it's a blowing up area right now
because of what everything that happened
with the vaccines
well it's going to keep going then
because you know
that whole idea of delivering
sort of
you know custom rna that was people were
doing for cancer therapy has just been
accelerated by a decade or something oh
most heavily
so you know it's gonna keep going
um
so we care about this
uh okay let's just look
and and this is also where multi-strand
proteins would fit
what is it
that's a much more senior field that's
been around for a very long time yeah
what's an example of a multi-strand
protein
will be a multi-strand
where each of the strands are connected
by multiple disulfide bonds
sometimes you call that quaternary
structure and uh in the peptide world
yeah the protein okay right i've heard
of that
okay so wait a minute so that is a case
where
using the same hybrid strand idea or
using a different no that's for a single
sequence of that's for something which
is in a one-dimensional sequence but the
thing you're referring to is two strands
next to each other so to speak being
connected is that true yes yes
which has their own indexing nightmare
yes
these will be consistent because we can
use
we can just say that a single motif just
always starts at one
and use the same scheme there's no
conflict between the two
when we're going in sequence collections
okay what is the sequence collection
that's what we're looking at at now
these collections of sequences that are
are bonded together so we have multiple
composite strands or multiple is that a
standard name for such things
we don't have to name them because all
we're doing is looking at nested
biosequences
but we don't have to name the construct
other than in documentation
it's just a nested biosequence and then
the question is how is the thing knitted
together so i mean this type of question
shows up i mean this is also related to
the ports question for graphs and so on
that is
uh
and for neural nets and so on i mean
that is right now you are doing
everything by numbers
it is not self-evident that you wouldn't
want maybe maybe i don't know do you
want a named port
somewhere as in
a named position as opposed to just
numerical positions
that would be cool that's useful
yeah we
it's i think in the section that john is
close because it's not ready yet but of
course we want to annotate the whole
strength anyway so this would fall into
this world
oh boy so
characters yeah is is going to need
annotations yeah heavily so so right so
you can imagine moving to a
a data structure that
could allow arbitrary inter linkages
that wasn't just a sequence of monomers
that could be
could be built upon graph
and could put arbitrary annotations on
the on the vertices and arbitrary types
of edges
i mean look in the end
okay in the end we are
yeah we are defining a graph
and i suspect one of the nasty things is
you'll want to annotate spans
and that's going to be ugly yeah
that's for sure we'll need that
coding sequences and all the rest
richard is commenting about a thing
called porgy but that apparently does
port craft rewriting okay interesting we
should look it up thank you
um
i mean we don't have to
come up with the ultimate solution for
everything because the fact that we are
still in the linear world does simplify
quite a few things here
as opposed to what circular world or no
arbitrary branch looped
right but i mean generally people
attempt to do that i mean smiles for
example or the generalizations of smiles
attempt to kind of describe you know
have some sort of pseudo-linear
specification of something which might
have all kinds of extra linkages in it
and in the end you just have to give a
graph
yep right in the end i mean you need to
have something that internally is
represented as a graph with fast lookups
of uh annotations and fast yeah
programmatic access to those annotations
um
okay so let me just understand it and
in i mean one of the questions here is
for example you know in neural nets we
have net chain and we have net graph
a net chain is for the simple case where
you just have
i mean
the fact is
in
right i mean
and the question here is what we don't
want to do is to have a sort of slippery
slope where we're getting more and more
and more complicated you know
bells and whistles on top of a linear
chain thing
realizing that actually the interesting
cases are going to just be graphs and we
might as well you know bite the bullet
and just use graphs
and then have various utilities that
that sort of mass produce
uh kind of
you know graphs a certain structure
having the base thing be a graph
rather than the base thing be something
with an ornate
kind of a bizarre
unknown elsewhere syntax
and it worries me a lot that you're
talking about annotations because that's
going to mean if you have span
annotations i don't see how that can
possibly work with part numbers
unless what you do is you say just like
the bonds are referring to
spans
so somehow there can be an annotation
that separately refers to a span but
that's not how we've done annotations in
other kinds of structures
it's similar to how audio does
annotations i think right i mean so
audio does annotations much differently
than graph when i i do so much so that i
don't fully understand
when i look at two examples but so i
think audio
when you annotate an audio uh
object you are specifically annotating a
region in it yes you are
i thought those were decently unified
but maybe not
just i mean it seems different to me
because i think i tend to think in terms
of specific vertices and
right
um
right well i understand that i mean i
understand but so so if i look up
annotation
um
i think you want to look up annotate
or even audio annotate
what's this doing
what the heck is that
a region of interest and values
a list of regions
a region of interest and values
i see so that's that's an after the fact
annotation
that's not a wrapped annotation
by which i mean one thing you could
imagine is you have a list
and you put a symbolic wrapper around a
part of it that represents an annotation
which is what you do inside graph for
example for individual edges and things
like this
but here
what this is saying this is an after the
fact thing
where you come in and say
i want this region of interest in the
audio to be annotated with this value
does that make sense yeah yes
i mean actually
the fact that internally sound is
discretized there's also the difference
between something continuous and
discrete
in the discrete case you can
annotate every single of the finitely
many things in a continuous
case you need a different machinery
i understand
richard is commenting seems like a job
for labeled hyper edges
you know one day we are going to have to
introduce hyper graphs i i have used
typographs now so much in the last
couple of years and i have
you know unfortunately there are many
different kinds of hypographs which
doesn't help
between ordered ones non-ordered ones et
cetera et cetera et cetera it's a more
complicated story than with graphs where
sort of the directed versus undirected
graph cases
are
you know they're not too hard to
understand the relationship
okay this is lovely so do we have a way
of i mean did we make this kind of um
uh
um
is this is this using secondary
structure computing software to do to
figure out what shape this will be
this is all all our internal
uh graph functionality
we've got functions in emerald that do
folding and pairing as a thing
okay but i mean is this a representation
of
what that rna strand would actually look
like
oh that's a dna strand so
uh
yeah no this is pure basically craft
layout this does not
any physical interaction into your
account
right
unfortunately this meeting really should
have been scheduled for significantly
longer this is a complicated area with
lots of complicated decisions to make um
and i need to go to something different
uh but at least with the beginning part
you are okay we go ahead and really
implement i think so i think so i mean
but i'm a little concerned about this
whole annotation indexing etc thing i
just think we need a nice principle way
of approaching the whole thing and uh we
i mean we haven't really i mean
brian have has emerald figured out
some
sort of systematic way of doing this or
or
do you do you think you have a good
design pattern for this
i would say
no because it's
what we do anyway is people manipulate
it as the pictographic form anyway we
actually box form the whole thing up and
they we have we go the direction just
like we do with molecule where there's
like drawing tools use your mouse to
make it
so we haven't focused too much on the
underlying wrap you guys are doing a
much better job than we are of saying
this is what the one-dimensional
representation should look like
fair enough i mean i think we're we're
imagining programmatic chemistry as
opposed to point-and-click chemistry
which may be completely unrealistic
because i i don't know what
uh no it's better from a functional
perspective because we end up writing
functions and then we have to deal with
the headache that is our representation
when we're in the weeds of those
functions like the thing that generates
the foldings right that's a real
function and
right
simulate folding is a function in
emerald right
right
no i mean i think
uh
yeah well
i'm i'm hoping to understand this stuff
a lot more when i'm i'm i'm uh as you
know i'm trying to use some ideas from
our physics project and particularly
these multi-way system concepts and
things to understand some kind of way to
approach chemical reaction networks more
about that some other time
um
i need to go and uh sorry um
uh this was very useful thank you yeah
a lot of nice stuff here a lot of
interesting comments on our live stream
thank you for that and richard is making
one more comment here
rather than spans when they use a hyper
edge also beats metagraphs which allow
edge edge relations
wow i'm not i'm not familiar with
metagraphs that's an interesting concept
i judge relations that sounds like
higher category theory
of of kind of um
uh you know morphisms between morphisms
and things
um
interesting
okay all right i gotta go see you guys
later